today the British economy was hours away
from what could have been one of the
most serious Financial crises in decades
Iran on Pension funds and if the bank of
England hadn't intervened by buying up
government bonds there could have been
mass insolvencies by this afternoon do
you take responsibility no the bank of
England did its job the bank of England
intervened in the market to ensure
Financial stability that is exactly what
the Independent Bank of England is there
to do and I think the market has
responded positively to that so I think
we should all be very pleased the bank
of England has done that what we're
focused on as a government is making
sure the economy grows making sure that
businesses do well making sure people
can get into better paid jobs that was
the point of our growth plan last week
and that's what we're focused on
delivering I think everyone can agree
that it is good news that there was an
intervention but I guess the thing is
why they felt the needs to intervene in
the first place and in the five days
since the budget a third of Residential
Mortgages have been pulled from the
market interest rates now predicted to
double next year I mean that could mean
people losing their homes and it's
self-inflicted it's a budget that
decided to prioritize helping the one
people who the one group of people who
don't need help those on over 150 000
pounds a year are you going to change
course well no we're not let me just
first of all take the point about what
the uh event on Friday the chancellor
statement was designed to do so to be
clear the abolition of the additional
rate the 45p tax Band uh constituted
less than one twentieth less than five
percent of the fiscal Firepower that was
deployed things like the national
insurance tax cut uh bringing forward
the cut to the basic rate of income tax
and holding down corporation tax for
businesses big and smaller like benefit
everybody and there are 30 million
workers who benefit from those National
Insurance and income tax decreases it
were was a an event a statement designed
to help everybody in the country
directly and by getting the economy to
grow it will help everybody as well now
you made a point before that about you
know has this caused the volatility in
the market and I think if you just take
take a step back and look at the markets
whether that's currency markets or Bond
markets interest rates over the last
year or so and the last nine months in
particular globally we've seen quite a
lot of I'm going to have to I'm going to
have to come at you there because you
know you're talking about global forces
but it is clear that the UK is an
outlier here let's just look at the
yield now 30 years just let me finish
look at the yield on 30-year government
bonds this is the cost of UK borrowing
effectively the Bedrock of these Pension
funds that the bank of England had to
intervene to try and support well I'm
not sure this is the UK is a clear
outlier so I'm not sure this chart's
gonna be up today I checked looked at
bond yields before coming in and the U.S
Bond rates and UK Bond rates are pretty
are pretty I don't know where they got
pretty close together right that is up
today you can see it dropping a little
bit but you can see the huge increase
the red line is shooting ahead of the
others you're talking about global
forces well you also talked about
interest rates right I mean if you look
at the interest rate cycle across the
globe interest rates are increasing and
actually higher in the United States
than they are in the United Kingdom so I
think we are looking at Global changes
Global volatility it's been happening
not just in the last few days it's been
happening in the last few months I mean
the bank of Japan made an intervention
in their currency Market just a few days
ago and we're responding to these same
Global forces but the government what
the government is focusing on because
obviously the monetary policy is the
Independent Bank of England's preserve
but we're focusing on as a government is
growth is making sure our economy is
freed up to create the jobs of the
future to create better paid jobs as
well and that's what the growth plan is
designed to do we've also so you
mentioned inflation interest rates we've
also intervened decisively in the energy
markets to make sure that households
don't face bills of three four five
thousand pounds this winter which was
forecast just a few weeks ago we're
making sure the average household
doesn't pay more than two and a half
thousand pounds that is a huge
intervention will help every single
household in this country and every
business as well as a huge intervention
but this is partly why and it was
markets are concerned as well because
look you've got this huge intervention
on the one hand you've got tax cuts on
the other and you haven't told them how
are you going to pay for it why did you
not publish the OVR why didn't you even
bother to get your sons done that's why
the chancellor of the exchequer has said
very clearly he said it on Friday and he
said it again on Monday just in case
anyone missed it that there will be a
full uh medium-term financial plan
medium term fiscal plan set out on the
23rd of November that will explain what
his plans are but it will include
getting debt over GDP down over the
medium term it'll be fully scored by the
obr and we should also just keep in mind
that we start today with the second
lowest debt to GDP ratio of any G7
country and billing the question you
just asked will get very clearly and
comprehensively answered including an
independent obr score on November the
23rd okay I I will I want to ask you a
bit more about that in a minute but just
before we do because it's really
interesting talking to you it's pretty
clear that you are not changing course
you're effectively pushing on there's
going to be no reversal of what the plan
of the government not at all because
getting because getting behind safety
because getting Britain's economy
growing is so important important to
raise wages it might be important to pay
the taxes my point is why do you think
you were wrong and so many other people
are you were right sorry yeah there we
go why do you think you were right and
so many people are wrong I just want to
look because here's the international
monetary fund they've said given the
elevated inflation pressures in many
countries including the UK your point we
do not recommend large and untargeted
fiscal packages at this juncture as it's
important that fiscal policy does not
work at Cross purposes to monetary
policy and they go on to say the nature
of the UK measures will likely increase
inequality a really a clear message
there from the IMF against your plans
and it's not just them the former bank
of England Deputy Governor Charlie Bean
so the budget went catastrophically
wrong the chief Economist at Capital
economics the idea is going to spare on
economic growth I find difficult to
believe even Julie and Jessup of the iea
usually someone who's quite Pro Liz
truss even I can't put a positive spin
on this why is the government so
confident that you're right and everyone
else is wrong what do you know that we
don't well first of all getting growth
going is is critically important to our
countries let me just answer the
question look if you look at our growth
um in recent years it needs to be higher
higher growth leads to more jobs better
pay and it makes us more able to pay the
tax bills of the future to fund the NHS
Health police and so on and that's why
the growth plan is so important it is of
course also important to be fiscally
responsible which is why the medium-term
fiscal plan and the accompanying obr
scoring is going to be set out in full
on the 23rd you know if you look at the
reaction to the statement the chancellor
statement uh quasi-parting's statement
on Friday and look at the response of
people like the CBI the confederation of
British industry look at the response of
people like the Federation of small
businesses or the British Chambers of
Commerce they all really strongly
welcome these packages and these
measures because they understand it will
help their members the businesses who
create jobs and who pay taxes it'll help
them grow and it is their opinion I
think and it's the way that their
members respond to this that I think is
the most important thing here quasi
quantum on Sunday there's more to come
are you planning more tax cuts I think
quasi-coating is planning to lay out our
approach to getting the country's
finances responsibly managed in his uh
fiscal uh medium-sum fiscal plan on
November the 23rd
um that is what we should be focusing on
I don't expect that to uh involve
significant measures on the tax side
it'll be looking at a long-term fiscal
uh prognosis okay so if you so if you're
looking at the long-term fiscal
sustainability and it's not going to be
so much about tax the elephant in the
room is spending are you going to be
cutting spending look we're going to
beat so first of all it's really
important to say we are going to be
sticking within the existing spending
envelope that's the comprehensive
spending review 2021 envelopes set out a
year or so ago that is very important
because we're going to live within those
means that means they make sure well no
you can look at it yourself you'll see
where what it sets out it means the
public services are properly and but
with inflation going funded tax changes
that you want to see it means spending
cards doesn't it well the comprehensive
spending with you like set out the
spending envelope we are going to stick
to that spending envelope which makes
your public services are properly and
responsibly uh funded beyond that we're
going to make sure that in the medium
term that debt to GDP figure which is
already the second lowest in the G7 is
on a downward trajectory over the median
term that is the responsible thing to do
and that's what the chancellor quasi
Crossing will be doing on November the
23rd my colleague Sam coat says the
cabinet have already been asked to find
efficiency savings is that true
well the government always wants to
operate more efficiently we want to make
sure that our taxpayers money money paid
by you know our neighbors my
constituents is spent as well as
possible and that it's prioritized
towards projects which deliver growth
you know infrastructure for example we
talked a lot about getting more
infrastructure built so obviously we're
constantly looking at that but I was
going to emphasize again we're going to
be sticking to the existing spending
envelope which was set out a year ago it
covers a three-year period we're in the
first of those three years now it makes
your public services are properly and
responsibly funded and we're sticking to
that so it's pretty clear that you say
you're sticking to the uh the envelopes
but with inflation that is going to be a
squeeze for many uh different uh
departments real terms cut you're also
well don't forget this spending review
by the way it did entail
um real-time increases when it was
written so just keep that in mind but
that was before inflation went to 10
yeah although inflation affecting the
public sector isn't as high as 10 for
various reasons we can get into if you
want okay um let's let's not do that
although I'm sure that many headphones
and hospitals will still be looking at
the energy energy bills that they're
facing but of course but of course
hospitals and schools are beneficiaries
of the business energy price guarantee
as much as you and I as individuals are
as well okay now
you speak you're not gonna I just want
to have a little look at the recent
polls that we've seen as well because
this is something that a lot of your
colleagues are going to be concerned
about they're going to have a look at
the market reaction to the budget and
they're also going to be looking at
things like this which is you know the
latest uh polling showing a record at
Labor leads up at 45 for labor the
conservatives on 28 you speak to your
colleagues is it right that letters of
no confidence the Prime Minister have
already started going in well I've
certainly haven't heard about that and
I'll be astonished if that was if that
was true like what matters isn't a snap
opinion poll done on a particular day of
the week it's not it it's a longer term
Trend than that well I'll tell you what
the longer term trend is going to be the
longer term trend is going to be getting
growth going which the growth plan will
deliver and when that delivers higher
growth for this country we're going to
see wages going up we're going to see
more and better jobs getting created
we're going to see a more sustainable
tax base to fund public services that is
what I think the public wants and expect
to see and when that growth plan
delivers in the fullness of time I think
the public will be enthusiastic about
that as people like the British changes
out well and as people like the British
Chambers of Commerce the Federation of
small businesses and the confederation
of British industry are enthusiastic
about it already two very quick
questions to end because we are out of
time are you going to recall Parliament
uh well that's not my decision I haven't
heard that being discussed we've got
party conferences going on
um so I mean that's not my job to decide
that but I haven't heard that suggested
and also where is listras
well I met this trust in number 10
Downing Street about an hour ago do you
not think that you should be out
reassuring people when we've about to
see a run on Pension funds when the bank
of England had to step in why haven't we
heard from her well at least trust is
busy you know running the country she's
busy setting our policies we were
discussing uh the medium term fiscal
plan uh with her the chancellor and I um
and she's getting on with her job as you
would expect her to be okay thank you
very much indeed thank you